hello everyone this video was actually a
suggestion from a subscriber he said if
I could show a ron weasley game and okay
I can't show her own Weasley game since
Ron never played the game but I can show
you the final position from the movie
and this is actually a chess puzzle
composed by the American International
Master Jeremy Suleiman and it's funny
when the first when the crew first
approached him and asked if he could
create a puzzle for them for the movie
he was very interested because he says
that he really enjoys movies and TV
shows but whenever he saw chess in any
TV show or movie that it was just bad
either the pieces were wrong or the
board was wrong or the language used in
the scenes was wrong but you know when
they were talking about chess and you
know there were things like when someone
thinks for really long and then you know
he found he finds checkmate in one move
and he was supposed to be a strong
player so a lot of things that never
actually happen so he was very
interested in he was going to set the
record straight and the short chess for
the beautiful game that it is and he
created this puzzle but it's not only
about solving the puzzle because okay
black is much better here but you have
this Bishop on a3 and this bishop was
Harry Potter in the movie and you have
to solve the puzzle without losing this
Bishop and this rock and f8 was harmony
and harmony also has to survive but okay
by the script run Iran doesn't have to
survive if you've seen the movie run
sacrifices himself and run is this
Knight and g5 so having all these
parameters you're welcome to solve the
puzzle and their opponent played Queen
captures on d3 and like I said black is
better but what the white queen is
threatening to capture the bishop on a3
you know to kill Harry yeah it's it's
very fun to call this Bishop Harry after
watching Simon Williams you know it's
hard to call anything but this pawn
Harry so yeah this is the position if
you want you're free to try and solve it
for yourselves you can't lose Harry here
on a3 and you can't lose her mind on f8
so you're free to pause the video and
solve the position and if you have I
congratulate you
it's not only a position you have to
solve what you also have to add some
parameters and for those of you who
haven't solved it well the idea is to
play rook to c3 this protects Harry here
on a3 and well the queen has to capture
the rook
so Queen captures the rook here and now
this Harry is still attacked but it was
important to remove this rook from c5 so
this C files were becomes available for
Harry so we have Knight to h3 check run
now jump stage three and sacrifices
himself we have Queen captures on h3 and
now since this rope moved from c5 Harry
simply jumps the c5 would check and the
White King has no moves only move is a
queen to e3 and now Harry plays Bishop
captures and e3 so here Harry knocks the
Queen down and it's checkmate and they
win the game and well it was a very nice
moment and but the worst thing is that
no one that was watching the movie even
chess players I couldn't couldn't really
see the position because in the movie
they only they only showed from the
position when Ron jumped to h3 the
knight sacrifice and this Bishop to e3
move and geremy said that he was
watching the movie and then he just said
wow they kind of really ruined this and
the worst thing of it all is that in the
credits after the movie they never even
mentioned him he said that he mentioned
the hairdresser is the delivery boy that
brought them doughnuts in you know
everyone except him who composed the
this chess position for the movie so
yeah that's how far down the food chain
chess is so that's it for this video it
was a it was a different video than the
others but I do hope you enjoyed it as
usual you can check to my previous
videos here and thank you all for
watching I will see you soon